Emotions involve four different response systems, our thought and appraisal,
our physiology, our expression and our subjective feelings. So let's start with
thought and appraisal, this is necessary for all emotions. We have to perceive
an event as somehow important in order to experience emotion, that is we have
to appraise the event as in some way harmful or beneficial to our well-being.
Benefits to our well-being make us happy, and harm makes us upset, depending on
what's harmful. For example, insult makes us angry, loss makes us sad, and a
threat makes us afraid. But there's also the threat of losing a sexual partner,
which can make us jealous. Now these are perceptions. They don't actually have
to be accurate. Misunderstandings, cause the exact same emotional reaction, as
an accurate perception. So whether we're really losing our sexual partner,
doesn't necessarily matter, as much as the perception, of if it's happening, or
could happen.